me imagino que todos ustedes alguna vez
o más de una vez han escuchado en
especial por los dominicanos que las
personas no quieren ayudar y que son
tacaños eso tiende a ser bien como
pero el día de hoy yo vengo a cambiar
ese pensamiento esa perspectiva porque
como bien mencionaron en base a mi
experiencia yo soy una de las fundadoras
de una plataforma que ha podido recaudar
aquí en república dominicana más de 16
millones de pesos y haber ayudado a más
de 300 causas con la ayuda de miles de
dominicanos
y yo sí creo que los dominicanos y las
personas alrededor del mundo si quieren
ayudar lo que sucede es que tienen que
cumplirse ciertos requisitos para que
las personas se animen y quieran ayudar
y eso es lo que hoy vengo a presentarles
el primero de ellos es que las personas
deben estar y sentirse agradecidas
por qué digo agradecidas porque
normalmente cuando uno está agradecido
uno se siente feliz y cuando no se
siente feliz uno quiere que otras
personas y todo lo que nos rodea esté
como feliz y cuando tendemos a ver
miseria y pobreza y personas que tal vez
no están pasando un muy buen momento
queremos cómo compartirle de eso que de
eso tanto que hemos recibido
quiero darle por ejemplo un hecho de mi
vida
justo dos años antes de grabarlo del
bachiller mi mamá es profesora lo que
son profesores en el colegio saben que
realmente uno no gana un buen salario
como maestro ya veces no es suficiente
para pagar todos los gastos el caso y
mamá realmente ella siempre luchó con el
tema de poder pagar el alquiler
nosotros nos tratábamos de una forma
increíble había llegado un momento donde
ya teníamos casi tres meses de alquiler
ya incluso habíamos recibido la
notificación de que íbamos a ser sacado
de la casa si no pagamos el alquiler
porque realmente no estamos cumpliendo
con eso y yo me recordó como joven como
adolescente al fin yo no entendía y yo
me recordó que sería la calle o sea
cuando mi mamá me dijo eso y que mira
también o salgan de aquí como que esa
inseguridad que tú siguiente como tú no
tiene ni siquiera lugar seguro porque tú
está a punto de perderlo y como que no
hay nadie que de verdad pueda ayudarte
yo me acuerdo que yo para ellos era la
calle y lloraba y todavía como que me da
tristeza porque yo no entendía yo no
entendía cómo era que nadie en el mundo
podría ayudarnos el punto es que
justamente el día que subió la dueña del
apartamento y como que ya dio mira está
que las cosas que se tienen que ir a
ceder a nada
bajo un vecino y pago dos meses de
alquiler
realmente esos dos meses de alquiler no
nos sacaron a mi mamá ya mí como del
tema que estamos viendo de la pobreza y
de los problemas que tenían pero le dio
a mi mamá como tiempo dos meses para
buscar como otro trabajo aparte de ser
profesora durante las tardes y así poder
entonces ir mejorando y les digo con eso
y yo estoy segura de eso que si ese
señor por ejemplo se posta le hubiese
peleado o la novia rubia dejado que no
se ha sentido agradecido él no lo
hubiera hecho porque uno tiene que
sentirse feliz se agradecido y como el
concho leyó teniendo ese problema
yo quiero deberá colaborar y justamente
eso pasó con él vamos a darle ahora otro
ejemplo esto también un ejemplo real es
uno de los primeros casos con otro
tuvimos la otra plataforma él es perú
señor de 97 años que vive a pocos
kilómetros de acá en villa altagracia él
fue atropellado mientras vendía raíces
para sus nietos de huérfanos de padre y
madre eso es algo completamente real en
estas condiciones que ustedes ven vivía
ese señor así como lo ve en esa casa así
me cocinaba estaba pasando hambre miren
la delgadez que tenía
y nosotros publicamos en las redes
sociales y yo quiero que ustedes sepan
que fue un antes y un después en la vida
de él
porque sé claro se creó un grupo de
personas que estuvo dispuesto y cercado
dinero para construir la casa para
cubrir los medicamentos los alimentos en
fin todo lo que necesitaba y yo me
recuerdo cuando yo le prestaba a las
personas como que porque hacían eso esa
pero estas jóvenes que ven ahí eran
agradecidas porque tenían sus padres y
sus abuelos tíos había ocupado tanto de
ellas que ya como querían devolverle eso
y lo hacían a través de pelo
ouane cuál es tu nombre real
por eso yo digo que es tan importante
ser agradecidos y esto solamente son dos
casos no personal y no de plataforma
pero cada vez que nosotros preguntamos
los donantes en nuestra plataforma
porque sea algo el corazón no dicen si
ven por en un niño enferma y se mira yo
tengo millones no está agradecida que mi
niño está bien de que yo puedo dar todo
lo que le pase a mi niño que por eso yo
ayudé esta madre que tal vez este
medicamento hoy sí el sentirse
agradecidos es muy muy importante
otra cosa que se necesita como para
poder donar es el tema de la
credibilidad
asumo también que tal vez lo ha
escuchado antes porque el tema de la
credibilidad porque cuando uno ayuda uno
quiere saber que realmente ese dinero va
a llegar a donde tenía que llegar es
algo sea real y pasa porque por ejemplo
en el mundo no se sabían que cada año
son dorados más de cinco mil millones de
dólares para causas sociales pero
solamente el 19 por ciento es facebook o
sea es capaz de hacer de saber qué pasó
después entonces por eso es muy
importante crear credibilidad ahora como
nosotros creamos credibilidad bueno lo
primero es tener claro cuánto dinero se
necesita y qué se va a hacer con ese
dinero por qué porque si las personas
saben qué va a pasar una vez por ejemplo
yo digo voy a recaudar 100 mil pesos y
se sabe que se va a hacer con sus mil
pesos la gente está dispuesta a darlo
porque sabe qué va a pasar con el dinero
después entonces por eso es muy
importante tener un presupuesto claro y
saber cuánto se va a recaudar algo muy
muy importante es por ejemplo mostrar
qué pasa después que se dona y persona
otros siempre subimos actualización
en otra plataforma de que se hizo con
las donaciones pero en el caso de que
alguien esté empezando y no tenga ya
trabajo hecho una muy buena forma de
crear credibilidad es por ejemplo hacer
un vídeo con la persona con otra
tratando de ayudar porque así se ve que
efectivamente tu visita hasta esa
persona y esa persona es real y no es
básicamente un truco para ello sacarle
dinero porque realmente pasan redes
sociales que hay muchas imágenes muchas
cosas que no son reales ese sentido de
credibilidad cuando tú quieres donar tú
quieres sentirlo porque la idea ayudar y
eso lo que tú buscas ayudar
y el último requisito es que sea fácil
ahora porque es fácil
cuando un aporte da una ayuda
uno lo hace porque quiere entonces no
puede ser complicado este por ejemplo el
caso de una fundación y comunicar es
completamente real me está preguntando
si soy soltera o estoy casada o sea mi
estado civil por qué porque cuando uno
quiere donar incluso no quieres hacerlo
anónimo no quiere que la gente sepa
tantos detalles entonces si uno pide
tantos detalles para una donación la
gente se echa para atrás no sacarlo
porque todo quiere cosas quiere que
queda en el anonimato
y hay que recordar que realmente algo
voluntario aún no lo hace porque quiere
en el caso del vecino mío que nos ayudó
con este problema
fue fácil para él simplemente bajar al
piso y darnos la ayuda y eso también fue
lo que lo motivó aparte de que estaba
agradecido aparte de que era lo creíble
porque sabía que era verdad que estaba
pasando era fácil él solamente tenía que
bajar un piso para poder ayudarnos
así que yo espero que la próxima vez que
ustedes escuchen por ahí o les digan que
las personas hoy especialmente los
dominicanos no queremos ayudar sólo
queremos mejorar el país o son tacaños
piensen que realmente eso no es así
y si es una causa que lo está diciendo
una fundación o una persona que necesita
ayuda y tú te sientes agradecido sabes
que es una causa real y de verdad no te
cuesta esfuerzo poder ayudarla por favor
ayuda a la vida porque al final no será
nunca recordado por lo que tienes sino
por lo que haces muchísimas gracias